(upbeat jazz music)
(audience cheering)
- And also, we match,
and y'all match, and -
Did you guys send everyone
a memo? Like what happened?
- [Kelly] I know, I'm like, did I?
I was like, we all,
we didn't mean, we're
not going to a funeral.
(all laugh)
It's like, well you'd be
going to a very fancy -
- Or a black tie.
- Yeah. Well wait, so Maks and Val,
so out of your many years
on Dancing With the Stars,
who were your most memorable partners?
Who do you think?
Not to dis the others,
just, who's somebody that stood out?
- My wife. (laughs)
- Oh, well (beep).
(laughing)
- Good answer.
- [Val] Yeah my wife is -
- This is why you're still
married. Good answer.
(all clapping)
- It's a pleasure. And one
of the biggest pleasures,
is the dynamic personalities
and people that you go
through this process with,
and it's, I don't wanna say a gauntlet,
but it is something that
really brings people together.
And one of the partners
that I had a privilege
to be a pro partner with
on Dancing With the Stars
was Zendaya. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah. I forgot.
- [Val] And that -
- [Kelly] She was young, right?
- [Val] She was 16 and
she was just kind of -
- [Pryanka] Oh, 16 year olds.
- [Val] Trying to transition
out of the Disney...
- [Pryanka] Wow.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Star and yeah. The rest is history.
- I mean, yeah, that's
crazy career, that one.
She's so talented.
- [Pryanka] So talented.
- So Max, does it ever bother
you that Val won twice,
and you know, you won once?
I'm just pointing it out.
(Pryanka laughing)
Just pointing it out.
- I mean, it doesn't bother me because -
- [Kelly] Does he ever rub it in?
- Because he won twice, my wife won twice.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- His wife won twice.
- [Pryanka] Oh my gosh.
- [Kelly] Just holding it down. (laughing)
- [Pryanka] And then that -
- My six year old was in my
wife's belly I guess when
they won together.
So, he has a half a trophy.
I only have one in 17 seasons.
But you know, I gotta
say that my best partner
was probably the show itself.
- Oh yeah.
- You know, 17 seasons of
incredible opportunities.
Look at us now, type of thing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So we're grateful.
- [Kelly] That's a great answer. Yeah.
'Cause people don't,
like that's so, I don't know.
That's one of the reasons why I love
being part of The Voice, too.
It's like, it it does
that for other artists.
Like, not only the artists
you're working with
but also the coaches.
It like, kind of lets you kind of
reinvent yourself, too, in a way.
And that's really cool
how shows allow people
to really stretch their creative muscles
and be noticed in a different way.
- What we, what we kind of,
like, take for granted sometimes
is the people that we gathered
in those shows are your core
fans, your core audience.
It's the support system that you have.
Nowadays, social media craziness-
We can rely on people we've never met.
I don't even know where
they live, but I can always
get this nice message
that makes me feel like
you know what, I'm gonna go out.
I'm gonna do it again no
matter what the critics say.
'cause there's people that really are-
- Because that's why you're really here-
are the people supporting you. Yeah.
- Yeah, and popcorn.
- And popcorn.
Thank you for grabbing for mine.
Okay. Thanks.
- Um, it's so great-
- So far, this is, this is the winner.
- This is really good, I know.
I've never had that before. Damn.
- I'm gonna send you some.
- Oh no, I know.
Don't you worry. I'll buy it.
- Get it at Walmart and
Vons and Albertsons.
- I like to support you.
I'm gonna buy it, so-
(laughs)
- Priyanka and I were just
talking about her baby earlier.
So, you are having another
baby later this year.
So, congratulations.
- Congratulations.
(audience cheers)
Yeah. Another baby- together.
No, no, no, no.
That's exciting. Are you excited?
- I'm very excited.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, he's having another
baby. I just had a baby.
- Just to be confusing.
We just try to confuse
people all the time.
- Oh wait, that I didn't even
get that. You just had a baby.
- Having babies two months
apart, that type of stuff.
- Babies, on babies, on babies.
- [Kelly] Did you plan that?
- Yes.
- No.
- I was like, what?
I was like, that's crazy timing.
- We, we would love to have planned it.
- As a matter of fact, he and I, so I'm-
- [Kelly] As cousins,
they're gonna love that.
- I'm, I'm a January kid
and he's a March baby
and we have six years apart-
- [Kelly] Okay.
- difference.
And my son is six years old.
He's a January baby.
And we are having a kid in two months
in June and we kind of
missed by a couple of months
but they're also six years apart.
We did not plan it.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- So, we're having a lot of
these kind of moments. Yeah.
- But it's, it's been a lot of fun. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah? Are you sleeping?
- I'm a first time father,
- [Kelly] Okay.
- of a two month old.
- [Kelly] I was like, you're not sleeping.
- [Val] Yeah.
- [Priyanka] Look at that.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- [Val] A little gangster.
- [Kelly] I would snuggle so hard.
- My little man.
- Look at that.
- We waited for Kelly to come in
with babies, new shows and like-
- I love babies.
- Babies, babies, babies, babies.
- I love babies, too.
And I give them wh-
Mine six and eight.
They can wipe themselves at this point.
But like, but it's-
I love babies.
Especially the skin on skin.
That's my favorite thing.
I never knew about-
- And their smell.
- Oh, their smell.
- What's your favorite part of the baby?
- When they sleep?
(everyone laughs)
- That is true.
- Bath, bath time is my favorite
'cause they-
it's the one time I see
him, kind of, really content
and just chilling.
And I get to really enjoy that moment.
I'm not like, okay,
When, when, what's gonna happen?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Bath time is drastically
different after,
like, year three.
- Well first of all,
mine are six and eight,
so I have to like,
force them to put water on their body.
- You hose them down outside the house.
- They're like, ugh.
And I'm like, you literally
have dirt, like in-
like, your nails are brown.
Like, what's happening?
You have to take a-
they don't wanna do it.
I don't know what it is.
(audience cheering)
- So, Maks and Val,
you're both born in
Odesa, Southern Ukraine
and you now have a
nonprofit, helping Ukraine.
So, can you tell us about that?
- We had no choice really.
First of all, because
we're normal, good humans.
We have great family values
and we grew up with incredible parents.
But we're also first
generation immigrants.
We came from that place.
It's our home.
Our home became Brooklyn, New York
in the nineties and have been
in United States ever since.
But we are all from
somewhere in this place
and we value the values
that this country's on.
And so, you know, the support that we show
for Ukraine isn't just
because we're from there
but also because those
people want this type
of life and this type of lifestyle, so-
- And because it's, it's
I think, in my opinion
of how I view this country,
and the gratitude that I have
for the United States for welcoming us
I think it's the most
American thing to do.
- [Maks] Yep.
- [Val] Is to help those that are in need.
And so-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Val] Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Agreed.
I think it's really beautiful, too,
though, when you have
such a great spotlight
and you have this support system,
like this fan base,
and you use it for stuff like this.
- We also wanna highlight that,
on that video,
most of the people that came,
came without announcements.
We didn't ask for anybody to come in.
We just made a-
made it known that this
is what we're doing.
We're gathering humanitarian
aid for refugees,
for people that have been displaced,
first and foremost.
And, you know, they have lived through
the affects of this crazy-
it's a war.
It's the biggest since World War II,
in my opinion.
So, this was important for us.
The people that came
from all walks of life
are hundreds and hundreds of volunteers
that we never called,
and we're grateful for each
one, for every penny donated,
and we continue in our work.
- You know, we talk about it-
I think we're desensitized, almost,
'cause we hear it so much.
But it's a crazy thing to
hear come out of your mouth.
Like, someone being displaced,
that is literally your life
has been ripped from you
and you are put somewhere else.
That has got to be the scariest
thing in the entire world.
Like, not only just for an individual,
but especially if you're a parent.
How do you explain that to your kids?
I can't even explain
the most simple things
to my six and eight year old.
I get-
We just, we say it so much I think
and we hear it so much in the
news that we get desensitized
but it's, it's an incredibly sad thing.
- Yeah. I think a lot of these
conversations get hijacked
by politics and we're just treating it
from the perspective of just humanity.
- [Kelly] Basic humanity.
- Yeah. I-
We're not here to talk geopolitics.
We're here to talk about human life being
like you said, making-
- Worth.
- Being sacrificed. Yeah.
- And also in, just for context, we
are living in a generation
with the largest refugee crisis
in the world.
- [Maks] Absolutely.
- Between Syria, between
Myanmar, between Ukraine
there are the most amount of
displaced people internally
in their countries and externally-
- That's what I mean.
We hear it all the time,
- [Priyanka] Right now, in the world.
- and I think we're desensitized.
- Yeah.
- Doing this, Baranova27
is the name of this charity,
which is the address in
Odesa where we grew up.
Even starting that, you
know, I think a lot of times.
you see celebrities, whatever that means,
and you think infinite
resources and you think, like,
of course. Charity.
It just comes up.
Like, this is a really-
I don't know if grassroots
is the right term here,
but it's something that
our father started,
just out of sheer desperation,
and it was galvanized by volunteers
and you know, a year later,
we've shipped out over
a half a million pounds
of humanitarian aid directly to Ukraine.
- From a tiny, tiny city.
Fort Lee, New Jersey, just-
Bergen County, took on the,
took on the,
this the city took on-
- And you're showing
people what they can do.
What we're-
- [Val] Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. It-
Anybody can help and-
- So, from that one city
you could do that much.
Can you imagine, actually where
people actually have a
social responsibility?
And whatever you care for. You know?
- Yeah.
- That's why I think social media
does play an amazing part in
- [Priyanka] Definitely.
- society because we can't
use it for our benefit.
Like, connecting people
and really getting messages out there.
And I know everybody sees a celebrity
and they're like, oh
a celebrity, I'm like,
but that's the cool thing about
when you do have celebrity,
you have this spotlight
and you have this, sort
of, tiny superpower
and, it's like, to be able
to shine it on people-
Well, that's why I love doing this show.
To shine it on people
doing incredible things
and bringing that awareness.
Then, you bring it into
the home of somebody else
that might start something
in their community.
I think it's incredible.
Well, thank you for doing
that. It's really, really cool.
- Thank you, so much.